rogan had an experience he talked about
with his uh nine-year-old child in
california i don't know if you heard
about it i just heard about this morning
yeah so so there's this this story i'll
read it to you hang on one second so joe
rogan reveals
that woke anti-racist ideology was
pushed on his nine-year-old child in
california school this was a
post-millennial story when the whole
george floyd thing happened one of the
schools that my kids were going to back
in california released this email saying
that it's not enough to not be racist
you now must be anti-racist and my kid's
nine at the time what does that what
does this even mean rogan asked on
tuesday's episode on the joe rogan
experience these kids are not even
remotely racist like they have all sorts
of different kinds of friends i've never
heard them discuss it once it's just
like this person and she's nice to me
and we like to play together and we both
like the same things and so tell a
nine-year-old that you have to be
anti-racist well then they go looking
for racism they're gonna be looking to
confront it
that sounds very logical and common
sense to me how do you process what joe
was saying but but i thought we were
told they don't teach critical race
theory in schools isn't that the meme
out there oh it's only these
right-wingers making it up that we're
that we're teaching this stuff in
schools and yet here is joe rogan
obviously giving you an honest
assessment of what's going on there and
i don't know if you guys follow chris
ruffo by chance but chris ruffo is
basically the leader i believe he works
at the manhattan institute but he is the
leader at exposing what is going on with
critical race theory at all of these
schools what's on the show with msnbc
what's her name him and him and her one
back and forth with that woman who's
broadcasting from a mental institution
you know if you watch msnbc and you just
pretend that they're in a mental
institution it's actually quite
watchable if you watch it as a news
program it's pretty awful um but look we
know this stuff is going on and guess
who's going to fight it it's going to be
desantis they'll fight it in texas where
joe rogan what did he do he fled
california and he went to texas um the
funny thing about rogan is that rogan
was a bernie supporter and yet when he
signed the 200 million deal with spotify
what was the first thing he did he got
the hell out of california had something
to do with the taxes so we all have like
you know some inconsistencies in in how
we behave or what we talk about versus
how we actually
are uh but this stuff is obviously going
on they we almost killed racism in
america we almost how old are you all
you guys 43. so we're all ballparking
42 ish 42 58 right okay
we all of us grew up in a world that
racism was pretty much done it really
think about 10 years ago was there any
real mainstream racist person or racist
idea that was running rampant there
really wasn't and maybe maybe the you of
three years ago thought that trump was
like the the racist instigator to me he
was actually the reverse of that
completely he was of all the things i
thought of trump racist wasn't at the
top of the list okay fair enough and we
don't have to bother wasting time on
trump but the point is the who's who's
racist in america now
it's the anti-racist it's the people who
purport to be the tolerant ones that are
injecting race and gender and sexuality
and all of our differences into
everything there is literally
imagine how insane this would be show me
a republican show me the craziest far
right marjorie taylor green
something republican
and tell me what racist policy she has
does she not want black people to have
the same go to the same water fountains
or be able to get jobs it's you know
who's instigating racism it's the left
who want coveted vaccines to be decided
by race it's the left who wants harvard
to actually have quotas to stop asians
from coming in you know this crazy story
we had them on we had the young kid who
wrote wrote a book about yeah
there was a three-year lawsuit at yale
about that yeah so it's like
who who actually are the racist who
actually are the homophobes trust me i'm
not being hunted down here in florida as
you just pointed out it's like it's
completely fine it's completely fine but
they're ushering it back in we almost
did it we got it to this and now they're
starting to expand it again well let's
not forget this all started with uh
president obama race relations in
america were better under george bush
pre obama than they were obama coming in
uh trayvon martin could have been my son
the dallas
the funeral for the dallas police
officers all there's institutional
racism in the police department like he
ushered all this stuff back in there
were the riots in what uh not
minneapolis but baltimore baltimore
riots under under obama like this all
started with him this all starts in the
universities and that's like
like you said common sense is winning
it's not left it's not right it's those
who want to be free and left alone and
they see things like remember the san
francisco choir that they they said it
was a joke but they were coming for your
kids right it's things like that the
people are they're just done that's why
by the way then it turned out it turned
out like three of those guys were had
been arrested for pedophilia or
something i mean really like bananas
stuff yeah that's awkward yeah and it's
like you see terry mcauliffe run out in
virginia people are just sick of it they
just want to be left alone it's not left
it's not right it's like you said pat
it's common sense well back to you
what's
is that you know what i'm not even
getting political with it you know what
a losing proposition is messing with
someone's kids yep like whether you're a
democrat whether you're republican
whether you're pro-capitalism socialism
at some point if someone starts messing
with your kids all ideology is out the
freaking window and it's like don't mess
with my freaking kids here yeah ask
terry mcauliffe yeah well exactly that's
the elect that election went
click bang boom in two weeks
let me let me tell you so i i'm gonna
butcher who this was if i'm trying to
find the story to kind of tell you
exactly where this is coming from so
they went to this
community and this i don't know i want
to say indian reservation but maybe it's
a different one and they notice one
thing that nobody in that city stuttered
i'm like wait a minute this is very
weird how come nobody stutters here
and
they go around they're asking everybody
how come nobody stutters how come nobody
stutters how come nobody stutters how
come nobody stutters and everybody
starts saying what's stutter
what do you mean what stutter what is
the word stutter mean
what do you you really don't know what
the word stutter means no i don't know
what the word study means they go look
into their dictionary the word stutter
is not in their dictionary meaning
since they didn't know that there was
such a thing as stuttering people
stopped stuttering nobody stuttered
the moment you put that in there we
start thinking and we start stuttering
now how much truth there is behind this
i haven't spent my entire life
investigating this but there's a part
around it that validates a point of the
power of affirmations
if you keep telling me i'm a loser i'm
eventually going to believe it if you
keep telling me i'm not gonna amount to
anything i'm eventually gonna believe it
if you keep telling me i'm gonna do
something special in my life maybe i
have the ability to use all my talents
and abilities to do something big in my
life maybe i'm gonna start believing it
if you start telling america we're
racist maybe a small popular popular
a small percent is going to start
believing it then we are going to start
being racist if you tell us we get along
and we're making progress we're going to
be like oh what's up dave you're gay
you're getting married 40 years ago i
don't know today dude let's chill i'm
from iran oh you're from iran oh you're
from iran hey what do you have
exactly hey are we really going to do
this in a you know in a uh what do you
call this place in a bank vault and
you're going to close that i don't trust
an iranian but you know what let's do it
hey an iranian and a jew are sitting
right next to you
now it's like it's okay but this whole
concept of afro over and over and over
maybe i do have problems maybe america
does have problems i think that is one
of the biggest problems we have they
keep repeating the same [ __ ] and
some are starting to believe it have you
ever seen that incredible if you haven't
seen it you gotta you gotta show it to
your audience morgan freeman saying
exactly what you said
without limits with no
there's one that he did with lemon and
there's one from i think uh a few years
before that he did on 60 minutes with uh
ed brothers not ed bradley the other guy
mike wallace mike wallace yeah thank you
um it's it's absolutely and that's
exactly what he says stop talking about
it congratulations we'll move on and
then there's a great moment where uh
uh mike wallace is like well but don't
you want black history month and he
turns to him and he's like don't you
want white history month and he goes
well actually i'm jewish and he goes
well do you want jewish history month
and he's like no like his gut reaction
give it to me yeah and then he says it's
just can i tell you why your point is so
powerful about the stuttering thing yeah
um
because i i have a real life case
example about that i my freshman year i
played football in college right and the
quarterback on the team my buddy i was a
wide receiver he's my buddy he lived at
the place next door
had had a had a had a horrible
horrible stutter okay
his name was
tommy waters would stutter like crazy
okay
but when he would go into the huddle all
right guys here's the play today when i
got around i was like what the [ __ ] is
this wow but i hung out with him so much
and i didn't realize that i came back
home to miami for spring break or
whatever it was and my friends are like
dude why are you stuttering wow and i
was like what are you talking about but
i hung out with him so much that i
developed a stutter and then like my
friends and nobody called me out in in
school at college because it was like i
was with tommy that was my boy
and shout out to tommy if you're
watching this he's the best
um
and my friend's like dude you
you're a stutterer now and i had to like
hold on
yeah i don't i don't stutter and i'm
just gonna start talking regularly but
it's osmosis if you're around people are
like oh the people are racist this is
what's happening
thinking about it so your stuttering
thing is a very real-life example of
what can happen when you're crammed down
your throat with critical race theory or
wokeness or racism
you're you start to live it so think
about that that's you in college right
now you this we have all the adults
going through this through the media but
now to connect this to the rogan thing
he's talking about his nine-year-old kid
right so now a nine-year-old kid you
everyone knows this they don't care
about race they don't think about sex
they just want to play and now you
suddenly are injecting racism into their
world at nine years old
they are literally literally
manufacturing tomorrow's racists we had
got there we were done
nobody there was no really try to think
who who in mainstream america in the
last 20 years was truly racist promoting
racism that really wanted laws
that was maybe david duke
yeah i don't even know that he was
manchester united he wasn't mainstream i
don't even know if the guy's alive
anymore but yeah but there it was done
but now they are
keep creating a situation where
nine-year-olds
where nine-year-olds will have the idea
of race in their head when when there's
i can you imagine if joe rogan is
sending his kid to a school where racism
is rampant i mean every school in l.a
they proudly smack that we're
anti-racist here and it's like man were
you guys racist three years ago what was
going on over there if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]